Marie-Maude on nous dit toujours qu'il faut
protéger nos téléphones cellulaires
avec un mot de passe, qu'il faut pas
cliquer sur un lien qui suspect.
c'est une bonne idée de le faire c'est le minimum sauf que la réalité aujourd'hui Isabelle
c'est que les pirates
informatiques ne vont plus s'en prendre
au téléphone des gens, ils vont passer
par la porte d'en arrière
donc dans le système qui contrôle toutes les communications téléphoniques
et cette faille rend nos appareils tellement
vulnérables aux criminels
qu'on peut se demander jusqu'à quel point notre sécurité notre vie privée sont en danger
pour nous aider à tester la
sécurité des réseaux téléphoniques au Canada
nous nous sommes tournés vers
un représentant des citoyens, un élu
... compte donner à la police plus de
pouvoirs pour accéder aux données
personnelles ...
le député néo-démocrate Matthew Dubé
de Beloeil-Chambly, au Québec est
vice-président du comité permanent de
la sécurité publique et nationale.
Monsieur Dubé a accepté qu'on essaie
d'intercepter ses appels
il n'avait jamais entendu parler des
failles qu'on veut tester
bonjour Monsieur Dubé ça va bien?
Sa seule demande: acheter un nouveau
téléphone qu'il utiliserait seulement
avec des gens au courant de
l'expérience . - Bien, c'est un enjeu important
donc je suis bien heureux de pouvoir participer et je vois que vous êtes allez faire votre magasinage
-Oui, bien sûr. Donc on a notre petite
boîte de cellulaires comme les gens
doivent reconnaître ayant certainement
magasiné un téléphone pour leur utilisation.
oui la fameuse boîte. Oui. Donc, on a choisi
un modèle très standard très
abordable, mais qui fait la job comme
tout téléphone intelligent. Et vous
êtes allé l'acheter aujourd'hui même?
C'est exact. Donc j'ai été moi-même
en magasin acheter le téléphone,
comme si c'était un téléphone pour mon utilisation personnelle bien normale.
- Je pense qu'on peut commencer nos tests. Bien sûr!
Merci.
chaque fois qu'un abonnés de la
téléphonie mobile comme monsieur dubé
fait un appel
la communication est géré par un
système de trafic téléphonique qui
s'appelle ss système de signalisation
numéro 7
c'est le système qui connectent entre
eux les réseaux mobiles de la planète
y compris les réseaux des entreprises
canadiennes
c'est grâce aux ss est qu'on peut faire
des appels partout dans le monde sans
interruption
le ss est fonctionne un peu comme une
gare de triage où les trains changent
de voie ferrée pour aller dans une
autre direction de façon semblable le
ss7 dirigent les appels vers les
réseaux approprié pour établir la
communication mais un malfaiteur qui
obtient un accès à cette peut
détourner les communications et les
intercepter
c'est qu'à partir de ce système une
personne peut accéder à n'importe quel
réseau mobile de la planète s'il est
mal sécurisés
berlin la ville portent toujours les
marques bien visible de l'époque de la
guerre froide
mais de nos jours la capitale allemande
est le théâtre d'un autre type de
combat un combat beaucoup plus discret
contre le piratage informatique
nous sommes venus ici pour rencontrer
des gens qui sont aux premières lignes
de cette bataille
ce nom est le fondateur de l'entreprise
security research lab à berlin
l'ingénieur en informatique est reconnu
comme l'un des spécialistes des failles
des réseaux cellulaires ses collègues
et lui tente de déceler les brèches
qui pourrait être exploitée par des
criminels
aujourd'hui c'est vous comme l'être qui
va tenté de pirater en réseau de
téléphonie canadiens à partir du ac 7
et d'intercepter les conversations du
député matthew dubé
pour se faufiler dans le s est pas
besoin d'un arsenal sophistiquées tout
ce qui lui faut un ordinateur portable
et le numéro de téléphone du député
à partir du numéro le pirate peut
trouver dans un répertoire himdi de la
carte sim du téléphone
un numéro unique qui identifie l'usagé
avec les musées en main le pirate va
faire un renvoi des appels vers sa
propre ligne téléphonique avant de les
transmettre aux véritables
destinataires
quant à nous nous sommes allés nous
installer à la terrasse d'un café
berlinois un kilomètre des bureaux des
pirates informatiques
c'est de là que nous appelons le
député à ottawa oui oui bonjour les
faits du 20 février bureaux de radio
can oui bonjour ça va bien bosser
monsieur dubé avant d'aller plus loin
je voudrais m'assurer qu'on a toujours
votre consentement pour les pirates
informatiques y parviennent oui bien
sûr je fais toujours être est partant
pour me prêter à l'exercice
après cet appel le député dubé s'est
déplacé vers les communes où il est
attendu
nous l'avons joint une seconde fois
alors on sait que la chambre des
communes ciel jean ce moment qu'est ce
qui est important aujourd'hui sur la
colline
on jase beaucoup de l'alena on sait
qu'il ya des représentants
des pays impliqués qui vont être
présents à tahoua donc ça retient
beaucoup d'atouts qui démontre encore
une fois les lacunes du système de pay
phoenix a gagné bien après la pause le
pirate a déjoué système nous allons
vous dire tout ce qu'ils le trouvaient
j'en ai pas fait ça
après avoir parlé au député
fédéral matthew dubé
nous sommes de retour dans les bureaux
du pirate informatique pour voir s'il a
pu intercepter les appels aux oies
non
mais mes conversations avec le député
ne sont pas les seuls qui l'a
intercepté
il a aussi intercepté un appel entre le
député et son adjointe un appel entre
deux personnes à ottawa locaux
intercepté de berlin luca ne l'êtes
pas autre chose à nous montrer
il suit les moindres déplacements du
député dubé depuis plusieurs jours à
partir de son seul numéro de
téléphone est toujours en exploitant
les failles du ss est quand le système
de téléphonie mobile de berlin
le pirate a pu suivre par exemple
parcours du député de l'aéroport
d'ottawa à l'aéroport de toronto et
ensuite jusqu'à un automne dans le sud
de l'ontario
il est aussi en mesure de le suivre en
temps réel
il l'a repéré au parlement dès que
deux fois en oem à l'entente
si quelqu'un voulait le suivre à la
trace
il pourrait le faire nous quand ne
l'êtes école ste nour de sécurité
oui ce job est à berlin avait déjà
piraté des réseaux de
télécommunications en europe et aux
états unis notamment
mais c'était leur première expérience
de piratage de fournisseurs canadiens le
téléphone du député dubé utilisait
le réseau de rogers à notre demande d
téléphone branché au réseau de bell
ont aussi été testées
les deux fournisseurs de services les
plus importants au canada ont été
piratés avec succès par ces experts
les deux réseaux canadiens que nous
avons testés ont adopté environ 10%
des mesures de sécurité pour se
protéger contre des attaques via lé
ss7 ils se protègent contre le type
d'attac qui était populaire il y as
peut-être cinq ans mais le monde des
pirates criminels a évolué pour
plusieurs réseaux dans le monde
incluant rogers et bell
il reste 90 % du travail à faire pour
les sécuriser
vous qu'ils sont assez faciles à
pirater
oui si on les compare à d'autres
réseaux en europe et ailleurs dans le
monde
ils sont faciles à pirater téléphone
qu'on utilise iphone samsung autres y
est pour quelque chose
quel que soit le téléphone que vous
utilisez tout le monde est vulnérable
à des attaques
ce sont les réseaux qui font la
différence dans certains pays on a fait
de bons choix et de mauvais choix mais
au canada
les deux réseaux que nous avons testés
sont vulnérables à des attaques à
partir du ss7 la classe politique qui
soit vulnérable aux fins et du ss est
dans le système de téléphonie mobile
plus tôt cette année
de simples citoyens ont appris à la
dure qu'il pouvait aussi en être
victime en se levant le matin des
clients de la société de téléphonie
allemand aux deux telefonica ont
découvert que leur compte en banque
avait été vidée
c'est à cannes tannerie verdi
journaliste spécialisé en technologies
pour un quotidien de munich en allemagne
qui a eu cette primeur pour la première
fois un crime impliquant les failles du
ss cet été révélé au grand jour
j'ai rencontré une de mes sources qui a
mentionné qu'il y avait eu des attaques
contre des banques aux banques
je lui ai dit attends quoi je ne
comprenais pas il s'agissait d' attaques
contre des clients de banque en
utilisant le ss7 et je ne savais pas que
ça existait pour commettre leurs crimes
les pirates informatiques ont procédé
en deux étapes premièrement ils ont
envoyé des lits et malicieux aux
victimes pour accéder à leur compte en
banque
et pour obtenir leur numéro de
téléphone mobile
ensuite en s'immisçant dans le fc sète
les malfaiteurs ont pu rediriger les
appels et les textos destinés aux
téléphones des victimes vers leur
propre téléphone quand la banque
envoyé par texto les codes pour
autoriser des transferts de fonds ce
sont les criminels qu'ils ont reçu
d'autres secteurs qui utilise les codes
d'authentification par textos sont aussi
à risque
partout dans le monde y compris au
canada c'était la première fois qu'on
pouvait dire ok ce n'est plus un enjeu
théorique les gens ordinaires doivent
composer avec cette réalité et être
sur leurs gardes
pour les criminels il devient de plus en
plus facile de faire des attaques en
exploitant le fc sète puis un roberge a
travaillé durant plus de dix ans au
centre de la sécurité des
télécommunications du canada
l' agence fédérale d'espionnage
électronique il est maintenant pdg
d'une entreprise spécialisée en
cyberdéfense le coup et dans les
quelques milliers de dollars ont juste
pour faire la tacc alors là on atteint
un point où économiquement c'est trop
répandue c'est trop facile d'accès et
puis l'on commence à souffler des
conséquences suite à ces attaques
les compagnies ont essayé de resserrer
les liens mais c'est un poisson s'est
déployée dans des pays où la main
criminelle et nico anywhere nous il y a
aussi des entreprises d'équipement
d'espionnage qui vendent ouvertement des
systèmes d'interception de
communications via les 7 et 12
substances aux consommateurs et des
douzaines d'appel intercepté
simultanément premier set entreprises
et plus encore si le client dit quand le
ssm a été mise en place dans les
années 1980 la sécurité n'était pas
un enjeu seule une poignée de
fournisseurs qui se connaissaient bien y
étaient branchés aujourd'hui environ
800 fournisseurs de services
téléphoniques partout dans le monde y
compris des pays corrompus ont accès
aux eaux cette
et ce sans compter des centaines
d'autres entreprises de secteurs
connexes
ça donne des mauvais frissons dans le
dos 1 on est perdu contrôle le
contrôle et perdu totalement sur le
système de téléphonie internationale
départ à 13 heures
brigitte les députés vous avez
rencontrées vous a dit que le
téléphone dont il sent pour son
travail n'est protégé par aucun
dispositif de sécurité spécial
le député dit qu'il n'a jamais été
informé des risques liés aux failles
de sécurité dans la téléphonie
mobile par un étonnant c'est étonnant
et monsieur dubé faut-il le rappeler
est aussi vice président du comité
permanent de la sécurité publique et
nationale
de retour au canada nous nous rendons
voir le député fédéral matthew dubé
j'aimerais vous faire entendre ce que le
pirate informatique a pu intercepter
tendance à la qualité aussi ses
frères j'ai presque le goût de rire
passé tellement sûrs et elle sait
quelque chose vous faire entendre une
autre conversation ci a été captée
dans l'enceinte du parlement actuel
c'est ça veut dire qu'à quelques poids
de la chambre des communes au coeur
même du parlement canadien
un pirate informatique à berlin ont
été en mesure d'intercepter votre
communication pour les gens qui ne
connaissent pas le parlement où
j'étais physiquement se situe
directement à bas un étage en mode
bureau du premier ministre
c'est vraiment c'est quelque chose un
dernier exemple
mon adjoint parlementaire qui m'appelait
de mon bureau elle était située dans
le bureau comme toujours qu'un travail
puis une chance concrétisaient pas mal
sur personnes dont deux personnes à
ottawa dont la conversation était
interceptée par un pirate informatique
à berlin quelque chose de tout à fait
on peut s'imaginer dans certaines
circonstances que ça peut être très
dangereux et problème c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire je peux vous dire je
te donner un exemple qui a eu
l'attentât à québec dans la mosquée
c'est dans le centre culturel islamique
les les ministres de la sécurité
publique fédéral lui-même monsieur
goulet m'a appelé pour l'enquêté dans
le trait pour me faire le suivi de ce
qui est en train de se faire la
collaboration de la grc la sq
c'est la vie le pirate informatique a
aussi été en mesure de vous suivre
dans vos moindres déplacements partir
de votre téléphone mobile
je vous donne un exemple alors ça c'est
la carte du vendredi 15 septembre le
pirate informatique d'abord enregistrer
votre présence à l'aéroport d'ottawa
quelques heures plus tard il a noté
votre présence à l'aéroport de
toronto et peu de temps après vous
étiez rendu à un maintien du chômage
atterri à toronto que j'ai pu navette
jusqu'à monter une pièce savait pas
c'est très inquiétant même si nous
sommes au courant les techniques sont
connus depuis très longtemps les voir
en pratique
d'une façon si simple c'est
inacceptable pour ce cyber experts les
fins et tué ses sept dans les réseaux
de téléphonie mobile font du canada
une cible facile pour l'espionnage dopé
ou des entreprises les politiques
canadiennes un moniteur dans les
communications des politiciens aux
députés ou ministres ainsi que
d'influencer pas tant que tierce partie
dans des négociations très important
selon lui même des informations en
apparence anodines peuvent servir aux
malfaiteurs tout secret ou des choses à
cacher donc l'information pour yves et
peut être utilisé de façon malicieuse
pour extorsion donc forcer un politicien
à agir d'une certaine manière
chez nos voisins du sud les fins du ss
est inquiète les autorités au plus
haut point commun de security le
département américain de la sécurité
intérieure a publié un rapport en
avril dernier pour peut lire le ss est
utilisé dans tous les réseaux de
téléphonie mobile et vulnérables les
côtes électronique la géolocalisation
le déni de service et la fraude
le département pourra aussi que les
vulnérabilités peuvent être
exploitées par des criminels des
terroristes et des états étrangers et
que ça met à risque que la sécurité
nationale
l'économie et la capacité du
gouvernement fédéral d'exécuter des
fonctions nationales essentielles salle
contacts à ce que république
au canada le député mathieu dubé
demande aux fournisseurs de téléphonie
mobile d'agir je pense que la
responsabilité c'est de s'assurer
de la sécurité de leurs réseaux mais
aussi je pense que le gouvernement a une
responsabilité de vie fait je pense
qu'en termes de technologie on est très
très loin en arrière
e
radieuse et bell ont refusé de réagir
au fait qu'on soit parvenu à infiltrer
leurs réseaux il refuse aussi de dire
pourquoi ils ne font pas leurs abonnés
des risques possibles
ils s'en tiennent à des généralités
dans un courriel
rogers soutient que la protection de ses
clients est prioritaire et qu'ils
adoptent sans cesse les technologies les
plus avancées liées aux à 16,7 de son
côté pelle écrit qu'il travaille avec
des groupes internationaux et le
gouvernement fédéral afin de gérer
les risques de sécurité du ss est
mutisme aussi de la part des autorités
responsables de protéger le
gouvernement du canada contre des cyber
attaques
dans un courriel le centre de la
sécurité des télécommunications le
cst reconnaître les problèmes de
sécurité du fc sète sont connus
depuis une dizaine d'années et dit
qu'il travaille activement avec
l'industrie des télécommunications
pour en atténuer les risques quant à
lui le ministre de la sécurité
publique courant goodale s'est refusé
à tout commentaire s'en remettant ou
cst
au fil des ans on a vu différentes
brèches de sécurité mais rien de
comparable à l'envergure et à la
persistance des failles du ss7 des
milliards de personnes en sont affectés
depuis de nombreuses années il n'y a
aucune autre faiblesse informatique qui
a survécu aussi longtemps tout en
affectant un aussi grand nombre de
personnes en informatique on est
habitué à des failles et elles sont
réparés rapidement chaque mois on
améliore nos ordinateurs et bien les
réseaux téléphoniques n'ont pas été
améliorée depuis les années 80 ce qui
c'est
que malgré le sentiment que ça donne
je le sais que dans ma vie personnelle
et dans ma vie professionnelle
ça serait extrêmement difficile de
fonctionner s'en sort donc quelle est
l'alternative
je ne sais pas et c'est ça qui est sur
twitter la technologie nous est souvent
présentée comme un outil de la
démocratie et de la liberté
mais quand nos moindres communication et
déplacements peuvent être épié à
notre insu on est en droit de se
demander si cette liberté n'est en fait
qu'une façade
après la pause une intrigue
internationale
aucun élément de preuve prix sur les
lieux de son décès n'a été
conservés la piste de l'homicide a
été écartée